dans ce concert de louanges
on fait du chemin
au distante
key lorraine le nouveau personnage
marquant de la troisième trilogie star
wars fils de han solo et leia organa et
lorraine est un site apprentis du
suprême leader snoeck et servant le
premier ordre
il eut dès sa naissance un don pour la
force c'est pourquoi il fut envoyé par
ses parents à l'académie jedi de luke
skywalker cependant se laissant séduire
par le suprême leader il basculera du
côté obscur de la force et tuera tous
les apprentis jedi de l'académie de
l'udc et formera à l'aide de son maître
l'ordre des chevaliers de rennes
s'ensuivit un grand désarroi chez luc
qui décida alors de s'exiler et de
laisser tomber son académie afin
d'éviter que d'autres jedi ne bascule du
côté obscur cai lorraine sous les ordres
du suprême leader cherchera un morceau
de cartes afin de localiser l'endroit où
l'udc s'est exilé et le détruire pour
que les sites triomphe enfin car il est
le dernier des jedi mais calais lorraine
est encore un jeune site très perdu et
désorienté suivant l'exemple de son
grand-père dark vador il fera tout ce
qui est en son pouvoir pour lui
ressembler et terminer ce qu'il avait
commencé
l'étain personnage phare de cette
nouvelle saga ce qui lui donne d'énormes
responsabilités
néanmoins il reste très énigmatique sur
sa façon d'être
ce personnage est un vrai casse tête sur
ce qu'il est réellement pourra-t-il être
un agent double un jedi infiltrés c'est
ce que nous allons voir avec trois
théories que je vous propose
cette théorie est vraiment très
intéressante et peu d'arguments peuvent
la contester tout comme je le résumé il
y un instant
cai lorraine est un site apprentis de
snacks et un partisan du premier ordre
il souhaite terminer ce que son grand
père a commencé et c'est là que le
premier argument fait surface
anakin était un jedi qui a basculé du
côté obscur et qui est donc devenu le
seigneur dark vador où je veux en venir
c'est que cai lorraine pourrait bien
vouloir finir le combat que anakin avait
commencé et non celui que dark vador
avait commencé c'est à dire détruire le
mal en tuant les sites
c'est pourquoi il serait donc infiltrés
dans le premier ordre pour tuer de
supreme leader snook anakin n'a pas
toujours été un site il rebascule même
du côté lumineux à la fin de l'épopée de
puces revenons à la scène où le célèbre
contrebandier and soul aux moeurs de la
main de son fils kaï lorraine grâce à
ces théories la mort de fans solo
prendrait tout son sens il n'a eu
beaucoup de cran pour faire mourir un
personnage emblématique de la saga
cependant la mort de ran reste encore
dans nos mémoires avec plusieurs
incompréhensions
pour commencer partant du fait que cai
lorraine et un jedi infiltrés dans le
premier ordre dans le but de gagner la
confiance de sonnac et être un site à
part entière il se doit de faire des
actions lourdes et douloureuses comme tu
es un proche snow soulèvera même que
cette action sera l'épreuve la plus dure
que cai lorraine devra accomplir
affronter son père essayez de penser aux
paroles qui échangent le père et le fils
lors de leur confrontation dans l'abat
starkiller et lorraine dit veux tu
m'aider et anne répond tout ce dont tu
as besoin
hecquet lorraine tu donc son père la
mort de ran solo prendra alors tout son
sens hans et les situer par son fils
afin qu'il puisse accomplir sa mission
on le voit d'ailleurs souffrir jusqu'à
même pleuré car il n'a pas le choix vous
devez tuer son père pour ne pas se faire
prendre
enfin cela expliquerait pourquoi qu'est
lorraine est intéressé par ray grâce à l
équilibre de la force serait préservée
car à eux deux ils seraient en mesure de
détruire le suprême leader et puis on
pourrait donc expliquer le massacre qu'a
fait cai lorraine dans l'académie de
l'udc
ils tuent à tous les apprentis jedi pour
être vraiment acceptée par stock et donc
devenir un site à part entière néanmoins
lors de son massacre
il aurait caché ray sur jack ou pour
qu'un jour elle puisse devenir une jedi
et détruire le suprême leader à noter
que ré fut cachée sur jack ou comme le
fut cachée sur ta tweed ce qui nous
rappelle énormément l'épisode 4 a vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez
grâce à la précédente théorie nous avons
donc les deux facettes de kayes lorraine
le côté lumineux et le côté obscur
cette théorie a été écrite entièrement
par mois et j'espère qu'elle vous plaira
il se pourrait que kay lorraine ne soit
d'aucun côté de la force pour commencer
dès son enfance qu'elle lorraine fut
élevé par des pratiquants du côté
lumineux de la force
cependant il fut séduit par le côté
obscur et se laisse rejoindre stoke le
suprême dur le côté lumineux de la force
lui fut imposé dès son plus jeune âge il
n'a pas pu choisir quel côté ils
voulaient ça paraît un peu tiré par les
cheveux mais repensons aux histoires de
famille des solos et lorraine semble
détester son père même si au fond ils
l'aiment mais c'est pourquoi il quitta
la famille et rejoignait le côté obscur
par rebellion auprès de ses parents
comme une crise d'adolescence peut-être
le cas et lorraine ne connaît absolument
rien au côté obscur et a rejoint celui
ci seulement dans le but d'être en
opposition avec ses parents qu'ils
détestent et qui lui avait imposé le
fait d'être du côté lumineux dès sa
naissance
sinon on aurait très bien pu profiter de
ces histoires de famille pour l'attirer
ensuite nous remarquons cucq et lorraine
s'est trouvé comme un idole
son grand-père dark vador sachant qu'il
était un grand partisan du côté obscur
voulant suivre son exemple
il aurait très bien pu suivre au
naïvement les traces de son grand-père
dont le but de devenir comme lui tout le
long du film
nous pouvons voir que cai lorraine est
très perturbé il avoue même voir le côté
lumineux à certains moments il tua and
soul au possiblement pour se prouver
qu'il était un vrai site et se rassurer
de peur de retourner du côté lumineux
tout ceci reste un grand mystère et
énormément de personnes pensent que cai
lorraine redeviendra bon dans les films
prochain je suis du même avis que ces
gens là
cai lorraine semble réellement perdu et
l'impression qu'ils nous donnent à
travers le film c'est qu'il est très
indécis dans ses choix et certainement
quel côté de la force choisir mais
abrams réfuté la théorie que kay
lorraine soit un jedi infiltrés et si
cai lorraine était en fait rien de tout
ça et n'était seulement qu'un site
cherchant à détruire les jedi et établir
le premier ordre et la soumission dans
la galaxie
pourquoi qu'est lorraine est passé du
côté obscur abrams nous explique il nous
dit que cai lorraine admire profondément
dark vador et l'oeuvre qu'il a accompli
en tant que seigneur sith
il nous affirme ensuite que cai lorraine
sait très bien faire la distinction
entre le seigneur vador et anakin
skywalker qui avait pour but de détruire
les sites
ceci nous montre que key lors elle n'est
donc pas un site par hasard et que ses
motivations sont réels mais étant encore
très jeune ils échouent car il n'a pas
l'expérience de la force que possède son
grand père et se laisse séduire par
l'ennemi
cependant même avec les explications du
créateur le but final de kayes lorraine
reste tout de même très flou que
cherche-t-il réellement son côté un dc
nous pousse à croire qu'il pourrait re
basculé du côté lumineux
après tout comme je le dit si bien star
wars 7 est un calque de star wars cat
dark vador écailles lorraine sont
étrangement lié et cela nous est montrée
par l'isolation de vador pour kai
lorraine comme dans l'épisode castres un
personnage emblématique moeurs de la
main de l'ennemi soit obi wan kenobi de
la main de vador et en solo de la main
de kayes lorraine dans l'épisode 7
tout est encore possible il se pourrait
que kay lorraine tu le suprême leader à
la fin de la saga comme dark vador tu as
l'empereur dans l'épisode 6
on ne sait pas réellement sic et
lorraine a vraiment encore choisi son
camp seuls les prochains opus nous le
diront n'hésitez pas interagir via les
commentaires et à me laissèrent like qui
est très important pour l'émission merci
à ceux qui partageront la vidéo on se
retrouve très prochainement dans une
vidéo théorie que le leicester ce soit
avec vous cet argot rock